this video was made possible by
brilliant learn complex topics simply
for 20% off by being one of the first
200 sign up at brilliant org slash went
over this is one block in one city in
one state of the United States the US
Constitution's article 1 section 2
prescribes something that must happen on
this block representatives and Direct
Taxes shall be apportioned among the
several states which may be included
within this Union according to the
respective numbers the actual
enumeration shall be made within three
years after the first meeting of the
Congress of the United States and within
every subsequent term of ten years in
such a manner as they shall by law
direct what that means is that every 10
years the US government must determine
how many people live on this block in
addition to how many people live on
every other block in every other city in
every other state and territory of the
United States they must determine the
population of the country a
straightforward task but one that
thousands of US Census Bureau employees
spend a decade preparing for and a year
and fifteen point six billion dollars
executing it turns out that counting
more than 300 million people isn't
exactly easy instead of looking at how
these census counts every one of those
hundreds of millions let's rather look
at how they count the couple dozen
people living on this one city block the
bureau started preparing for the 2020
census on November 1st 2011 they have a
staff of about 4,000 who plan and
coordinate each census along with their
other programs and then every 10 years
when it comes time to actually conduct
the census they employ more than half a
million other individuals temporarily
the 4,000 full-time employees though
spend much of the decade forming their
operational plan the first draft of
which was done in late 2015 they then
spent the next three years refining maps
a significant element of this plan
includes deciding where the censuses
field offices will be located you see
the census divides the country up into
six regions which are headquartered with
permanent offices in Los Angeles Denver
Chicago Atlanta Philadelphia and New
York City then within those regions
these census opens up 248 temporary
field off
is to conduct local operations these
field offices are distributed based on
density so Colorado for example only as
four while New York on the other hand
has 21 each of these offices has to hire
hundreds or thousands of enumerators to
go out into the streets and conduct the
census finding half a million temporary
workers is of course incredibly
difficult and it's even more difficult
for the 2020 census given that the
country currently has the lowest
unemployment rate in recent history in
order to attract those half million
people they do have to account for the
drastically different wage conditions
across the country enumerators in Mesa
County Colorado where our block is
located for example are paid $16 per
hour which for this area is a pretty
decent hourly wage especially for a
low-skilled job requiring few
qualifications of course if you offer
that pay in New York City on the other
hand it would be far less attractive so
the pay there is up to to between $25
and $28 an hour
despite this decent pay though the
census still always has enormous
difficulty filling all their positions
so they spend years teeing up all these
workers the first of the temporary hires
for the 2020 census happened in mid 2000
18 that's because before the census can
go and ask every household on this block
how many people live there they have to
figure out where each of these
households is in the past 10 years new
houses could have been built structures
could've been subdivided and plenty more
could have changed so this is a crucial
step for accuracy in addition if a
homeless person is living in this alley
if someone's living in a motor home in
someone's driveway or if there are any
other abnormal residences this too needs
to be counted previously the census
would have sent someone to walk this
block in addition to every other block
in the country and mark down where each
residence is which clearly took an
enormous amount of person hours with the
2020 census though they're shifting
technique to use more and more satellite
imagery to identify residences of course
that's not perfect for example it's hard
to tell if this is one resonance or two
so for any areas that they're not sure
about they'll still send people to check
in person at the conclusion of this
process at least in theory they should
have a list of every single place where
live in the u.s. also in 2018 the Census
Bureau had to submit to Congress the
questions they plan to ask the American
public the census is incredibly simple
after all it has to be if they expect
everyone to answer it it asks for
background questions five about the
primary residence then seven about every
other resident of a given household
despite this the bureau spends an
enormous amount of time debating how to
ask these questions question selection
is so complex that they published a 98
page document explaining how they
selected the 2020 questions and their
wording for example in question 3 for
the non primary residence they added
specification on whether their relation
to the primary resident was as a
same-sex or opposite-sex couple in the
past there was the option to mark the
relation as a spouse or unmarried
partner but there was no distinction
between same-sex or opposite-sex they
did however calculate what percentage of
couples were same-sex based on how they
responded to the question asking if they
were male or female there was an issue
with that though say there was a married
couple living in this house consisting
of one man and one woman if the woman
accidentally marked her sex as male and
also marked a relationship as a spouse
they would be counted as a same-sex
married couple
given that the overall proportion of
census surveyed couples who are same-sex
is small these mistakes could
significantly skew the data with the
redesign of this question it acts as a
fail-safe so that even if the women in
the house marks her sex as male they'll
still be counted as an opposite sex
couple these are the tiny details the
bureau has to think about for each and
every question and change they have to
think about how to best structure them
to get the best possible accuracy once
they have their questions one of the
final things these census needs to
figure out is how they're actually going
to ask for responses our block is
located in Grand Junction Colorado which
is a small city so it along with most of
the country simply receives a mailed
invitation instructing the recipient to
complete the census online this works
well for most of this relatively urban
area but not for all of it for example
residences in this small section of
Grand Junction will receive both an
invitation to complete the census online
and a paper census form that's because
it's home to a number of assisted living
facilities and therefore a number of
older individuals who are far less
likely to respond online about 22% of
the country is classified by the census
as areas where individuals are less
likely to respond online and therefore
receive paper census forms as well there
are though areas were both of these
options won't work nearby Eagle County
for example has a population where
one-third are of Hispanic origin and
plenty of that population has limited or
no English language skills
therefore residences here receive a
bilingual invitation to complete the
census online there's then one more
category used in areas like castilho
County where there is a large Spanish
population and limited Internet access
where bilingual paper census forms are
sent out the census classifies the
entirety of the country into one of
these four categories in order to have
the best possible chance of getting an
answer when two offices are opened
employees are hired residences are
logged questions are written and letters
are planned it's finally time for the
census to start in earnest the first
census responses cannot happen until
2020 starts and all responses must be in
by the time 2020 finishes they have
exactly 366 days to count every single
person in the US and deliver that count
to the US Congress are blocked in Grand
Junction is far from the first place to
be counted though that happens in Chuck
sook Bay Alaska census workers arrive
there in late January 2020 to sook Bay
along with 200 or so other rural Alaskan
towns are exceptions in the overall
timeline of the census count as in
midwinter when the water and ground are
frozen one can get around relatively
easily on snowmobile whereas later on
when most of the country's census
counting is done it's very tough to
travel when the ice and snow are melting
down in the lower 48 the seasons are a
far less of a concern so in mid-march
95% of American households receive a
mailed invitation to fill in the census
online that includes our block but if
the earlier investigation found someone
living in a mobile home in someone's
driveway there they would likely get to
Dairy
hand-delivered mobile homes residences
and areas with recent natural disasters
or households that use Pio boxes don't
get mail delivered to their door so
that's when the census uses this hand
delivery technique which is used in
about four percent of cases a small
other proportion less than one percent
is visited and surveyed in person from
the first instance mostly in the most
remote areas of Alaska and Maine in
addition to on some American Indian
reservations on our block like most
others if households don't respond to
the first invitation they'll get a
reminder letter than a reminder postcard
than a reminder letter with a paper
questionnaire then one more reminder
postcard before the census gives up on
the household responding by internet
mail or phone typically about a third of
the houses on this block will not have
responded on time even though it's a
legal requirement non respondent
residences on our block will get a visit
from an enumerator but they might not be
the first to get visited in person
visits are prioritized strategically for
example knowing that college students
will start to move out from their dorms
and student housing starting in mid-may
they send enumerators to non respondents
at college campuses first each of our
houses will get three visits then if
they don't respond on the fourth they'll
also try to ask neighbors if they know
the details of the residents of the
given household
they'll try both the household and the
neighbors again for the fifth and sixth
try but then if the household doesn't
respond after five mailings six visits
and three knocks on the neighbours doors
then the census finally decides that the
residents must be on inhabited of course
in addition to counting everyone in
every household they'll also have to
count people who don't live in a
household for example to count homeless
people the census will set up at
shelters soup kitchens food vans in
addition to just going out into the
streets another challenge is counting
people who live and work on American
chefs who don't have a permanent
residence the census runs a special
program for this the maritime and
military vessel enumeration where ships
are sent census kits including
customized forms with different
questions targeted at seafarers these
are all then sent back to the census to
be included in the count and a variety
of techniques are used to assure that
nobody is double counted throughout the
second half of 22
in-person visits will finish up
special-operations will conclude and the
census will get into a huge number
crunching operation to figure out with
as much accuracy as possible what the
final count is they not only have to
give that total number but they also
have to break it down by state by county
by town by race by age by relationship
status and by much much more it takes
some time but there's a very very
specific deadline December 31st 2020 the
US Congress needs to know the count by
then in order to reallocate seats in the
House of Representatives proportionally
to the population of the states in the
2010 census 308 million seven hundred
and forty five thousand five hundred and
thirty eight people were counted as
living in the u.s. in 2020 the number is
expected to be around three hundred and
thirty million but to know for sure
we'll just have to wait for December
31st 2020
one of the big jobs at the Census Bureau
is as a maths addition and for that
according to their job listing you need
to be adept at things like number theory
statistics probability algebra and
calculus all of which you can learn or
brush up on with brilliance each of
their courses for each of those subjects
is interactive wonderfully designed and
helps you learn complex topics like
calculus not through rote memorization
but rather through breaking down the
concepts into small intuitive chunks and
then building it all back together this
is how you can truly understand calculus
or number theory or statistics rather
than just learning the process to solve
problems if math isn't your thing they
also have dozens of amazing other
courses on subjects like scientific
thinking quantum mechanics computer
science and plenty more to support
Wendover productions and learn more
about brilliant head over to brilliant
org slash Wendover and the first two
hundred to sign up there will also get
20% off